ils étaient plus de 40 à rêver d'un
siège à bord de la fusée lunaire Artémis
2 on n'avait jamais vu autant
d'astronautes au même endroit et au même
moment mais au fil d'arriver il en
restait seulement 4 3 américains et un
Canadien
fait partie du club très sélect des
astronautes et déjà une exploit en soi
mais réussir à faire sa place sur la
plus grosse machine volante de
l'histoire spatiale tient presque du
miracle originaire de London en Ontario
pilote de chasse de formation Jérémy
Hansen à 47 ans et a joué l'Agence
spatiale canadienne en 2009 il occupera
le siège de copilote sur la mission
Artemis 2 pour moi c'est un peu
difficile de croire maintenant mais
aussi je suis vraiment fier mais pas
pour moi mais pour le Canada si tout va
bien Artemis 2 décollera en novembre
2024 pour un voyage d'une dizaine de
jours la fusée géante rel la capsule
Orion qui réalisera deux révolutions
autour de la terre puis une autre autour
de la Lune avant sa rentrée dans
l'atmosphère l'objectif est de tester la
fiabilité du nouveau moyen de transport
de la NASA vers la Lune comme cela la
première fois qu'on va avoir une mission
habitée utilisant cette nouvelle fusée
là donc il va avoir un aspect de
participation dans le développement et
le test des différents systèmes il
s'agit évidemment d'un vol expérimental
qui comporte sa part de risques bien sûr
il y a des risques pour mission comme ça
quand on part la terre ça va être une
mission à peu près 8 jours et quand on
part on peut pas juste tourner retourner
le temps le Canada obtient le siège sur
Artemis 2 parce qu'il va fournir un
nouveau bras spatial à la NASA le Canada
le Canada développe également un Rover
pour la recherche d'eau sur la surface
très froide ou serait éventuellement
installé la base lunaire au total Ottawa
prévoit investir 2 milliards et demi de
dollars d'ici 2030 pour la Station
spatiale internationale le rover lunaire
et en recherche et développement le
Canada fait partie de cette histoire-là
qu'on est en train d'écrire c'est pas un
chapitre c'est un nouveau livre et moi
je suis fier de voir que le Canada va
faire partie de ce nouveau livre là de
l'exploration spatiale le choix d'un
astronaute canadien pour une mission de
cette importance démontre les liens 3
qui se sont progressivement créés entre
les deux agences ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada a Houston au Texas
de gagner le de gagner vous l'avez
mérité de mérité probablement le siège
le plus demandé de l'histoire récente de
la NASA tout le monde voulait avoir ce
siège là dans cette fusée là comment
vous vous sentez alors pour moi c'est un
peu difficile de croire maintenant mais
aussi je suis vraiment fier mais pas
pour moi mais pour le Canada aujourd'hui
c'était quelque chose extraordinaire
pour moi à écouter le Nasser les
États-Unis port de Canada comme ça
d'avoir des drapeaux sur la mur le
ministère le ministre champagne était là
j'étais vraiment fier de le Canada
aujourd'hui
et cette mission quand même
expérimentale c'est la deuxième fois que
cette fusée là voyage pas beaucoup la
première fois il y a pas d'équipage je
sais que vous êtes un pilote militaire
vous êtes militaire pilote mais c'est
risqué
bien sûr il y a des risques pour mission
comme ça quand on part la terre ça va
être une mission à peu près wish 8 jours
pour aller
pour de faire aller-retour à la lune et
quand on part on peut pas juste
bien sûr mais on a une équipe ici un
grande équipe incroyable et j'ai grand
confiance dans cette équipe vous vous
avez été entraîné deux ans pour venir
devenir un astronaute pour être accepté
pour devenir un astronaute bon c'est
très long c'est très complexe il y a
énormément de gens qui demandent d'être
reçus très peu le son maintenant en plus
vous devez continuer à vous entraîner
encore longtemps
pour cette mission ça va être un peu
différent parce que c'est la première
fois alors c'est plus le test que les
cours de l'entraînement on va juste
travailler avec les équipes les experts
de les systèmes pour le capsour et on va
appuyer des solutions ensemble je
reviens ma question au départ nous on
l'a pris aujourd'hui mais quand on vous
a dit que ce serait vous qui ait choisi
écoutez il y a 45 astronautes en tout
c'est tout le monde veut être là comment
vous sentiez
chanceux bien sûr
et c'est une chose sérieuse aussi c'est
un grand responsabilité
mais quand je connais les autres normes
j'ai eu une grande confiance
l'équipage pour un master je les connais
bien ils sont mes amis aussi je sais
qu'on peut le faire
un jour vous allez vous asseoir sur le
dessus de cette énorme fusée là vous
avez jamais été dans l'espace auparavant
il y a quelque chose exactement j'ai vu
la lancement de One et c'était
absolument incroyable de puissance était
incroyable et je sais sur le texte sur
la fusée ça va être quelque chose c'est
un peu de rock n' roll un petit peu vous
êtes prêt je suis prêt et je suis excité
et je suis vraiment fier pour le Canada
bien faire Canada
merci beaucoup